i can't breathe george
floyd's words during a long agony of more than
8 minutes and 46 seconds are not only the
cry of an instant but the injustice
and reality of our times because
police violence suffocates
blacks more than whites  because
cobat's health and socioeconomic crisis is
suffocating blacks more than
whites because climate change is
whites rosa parks ended up in jail
for refusing to give up her seat to a
white and being left in the back  from behind
the bus
martin luther king paid with death for
a life dedicated to ending
racial discrimination in the united states but the
inequality and pain caused by
discrimination have not prevented
his dreams from living decades later
the cry for equality and justice
of the millions of people who
in recent weeks
all the streets of the world have
given us hope, a hope that
asks for commitment and as a representative  As representatives of
European citizenship, we have the
obligation to eradicate the structural racism that is
still latent in our
cities and in our towns. It
is unacceptable that since 2008
the anti-discrimination directive has been blocked in the council
and I see the
Nadal police station here and I hope to have
she is a good accomplice in
getting this issue unblocked because we
need legislative instruments
to be able to put an end to racism
in europe as well at a time when
political parties are reborn in europe
that declare themselves racist we know that
peoples who do not know their history are
doomed  to repeat it a citizenry
subjected to discrimination because of their
skin color sex religion is doomed to
failure we can only achieve
progress in our societies
if we first guarantee that all
human beings are
equal and thanks to the voices of
millions of citizens
have remembered that black lives
they matter from the European Union we must
speak loud and clear forever remove
the white knees from the
black necks at last the same